I'm excited today to tell you about a
really fascinating cryptocurrency
project that has a lot of potential to
disrupt the cryptocurrency space and
really solve a lot of problems that we
commonly see in crypto problems I talk
about all the time actually and it's a
platform called Puma pay we partnered
with Puma pay to create this video and
they're doing some very cool things I
just did an interview the other day on
the David Pakman show where we were
talking about the downsides of crypto
and where it can sometimes fall short as
an actual mode of making everyday
payments and fall short of bringing new
convenience and reduced transaction
costs so just average people in contrast
to things like HX and PayPal and credit
cards most people don't know how to use
crypto in a way that's actually going to
make their lives easier and maybe even
more importantly most businesses don't
know how to use cryptocurrency in a way
that's going to make sense for them and
I think every anybody would acknowledge
that these are things that are
inhibiting mass adoption of crypto and
growth of the entire crypto industry and
crypto market right now and these are
exactly the problems that Puma pay is
trying to solve what they're focused on
is making it easier for businesses to
accept crypto where profitability is not
hindered by transaction costs where
businesses participating in transactions
can actually trust one another and where
customers themselves actually have a
practical way of using crypto for
everyday purchases Puma pay is an
all-in-one solution for payments that
basically takes the convenience of
payment cards and combines it with the
technological advantages of blockchain
technology and it all happens in an
ecosystem where we have the security
benefits of decentralizing credit card
processing the benefits of reducing
transaction costs by up to 15% and in
general streamlining and optimizing
peer-to-peer billing in many other ways
through taking advantage of what
blockchain has to offer and the ways
that blockchain can improve traditional
payment paradigms so let's dig into the
benefits
and how it works Puma pay is basically a
blockchain based billing protocol that
doesn't have the weaknesses that we
often see in kryptos like bitcoin and
litecoin and it's accessible in both
online and offline markets Puma pays
full payment protocol uses a brand-new
smart contract architecture which is
essentially inversing the mechanics of a
crypto transaction instead of the
customer sending or pushing funds a
business is pulling funds from a
customer's wallet
based on terms that have been
pre-approved and this was what makes all
of the other features on the platform
possible the Puma paid token fuels at
all it's called the PMA this is the
mechanism of payment between businesses
and customers in Puma pays ecosystem and
the platform allows businesses to choose
all kinds of billing models it could be
single payments they could be scheduled
payments monthly subscriptions paper use
shared payments and Puma pays the first
platform with such flexible payment
options over the blockchain back in
October of 2018 they were the first ever
a company to introduce recurring
payments on the blockchain this is
actually a big deal and now they're
pushing the boundaries of what the
technology can do even further the
platform is able to adapt to almost any
kind of business logic transactions over
the Puma pay protocol are totally free
with the exception of a small gas fee
payable to the etherium blockchain but
there's no middleman all transactions
are made directly from business to
customer through the blockchain and
businesses don't have to wait days to
receive the funds because all
transactions are processed on the
blockchain in mere minutes a huge
benefit to using blockchain like this is
that all transactions are final and
immutable which means that the
chargeback risk is completely eliminated
there's no risk of crypto volatility
because puma pays fiat settlement layer
guarantees liquidity by locking the rate
of the PMA token at the moment the
transaction takes place and through this
fiat settlement layer businesses get
funds as fiat to their bank account
without many of the hassles and costs
that often have to be endured when one
is liquidating crypto into fiat currency
something we
dealt with in fact this is an annoyance
that as a business owner who accepts
crypto as payment I'm very very familiar
with now customers using the platform
have a wallet where they can approve
withdrawals from businesses
pre-authorized payments set withdrawal
limits and customers are actually able
to use crypto to buy things in their
everyday life because on the other end
Puma pay is providing businesses with
the tools that they need to accept the
crypto in the first place and what's in
it for the businesses is that they can
now tap into the billions and billions
of dollars worth of crypto worldwide
that businesses for the most part have
been missing out on there's over a
hundred brands that have actually
already committed to using the Puma pay
platform including some big names like
wix.com Puma pay makes the integration
painless with their business console
this is another reason that they're
bringing in a lot of early adopters and
the business console is also where the
business sets up they're building models
and manages every aspect of accepting
PMA tokens if you want to start using
business if you are a business that
wants to start using Puma pay better
said you merely have to go to the Puma
Pay website and register the know your
customer is compliant with all
regulations they've done a great job of
streamlining this process and just
making everything it's got to be easy
for businesses who want to do something
like this and Puma pay makes it really
easy to integrate Puma pay also makes it
really easy for crypto savvy businesses
and crypto savvy customers to find one
another their service called Puma pay
pride is a directory of businesses that
have adopted the Puma payment system and
it basically acts as a hub where
customers can find them and where Puma
pay integrated businesses can promote
their products and Puma pay pride will
soon be integrated into the Puma pay
mobile Wallet app with an interface that
makes it easy for customers to search
and browse and creates an efficient way
to use crypto as a means of payment
it'll let businesses expand their
customer base it'll allow customers to
spend crypto on e-commerce stores in
ways that they weren't previously able
and it'll do it all with a level of ease
that just didn't
this previously and it will allow
businesses to make use of a really
unique marketing tool that I'm not aware
of existing ever anywhere else where
businesses can create communicate and
promote offers directly to crypto hole
holders within the customers wallet so
let's talk about the wallet a little bit
more the whole point of the wallet is to
make everyday use of crypto as a means
of payment viable and efficient for
customers it's a native wallet designed
to fully immerse customers in the Puma
pay ecosystem it gives them an easy way
to buy products and services from
businesses that accept that p.m. a token
as a method of payment the wallet is
available for iOS and Android you can
store send receive and exchange PMA
tokens Bitcoin litecoin coin aetherium
any kind of ERC 20 token whether it's
Cardno
bitcoin cash ripple - stellar these are
crypt those that will be supported on
the wallet very soon and you can manage
every aspect of your subscription
payments to businesses that use Puma pay
as well as the other types of payments
that I mentioned payment sharing as an
example they even have a Chrome
extension that lets you pay businesses
straight from your browser using the
same private key that you use on your
wallet and on other devices so let's
talk about the project itself
Puma pay had a hugely successful private
sale last year they raised over a
hundred and seventeen million dollars
this was one of the bigger I SEOs of
2018 the project is led by CEO Joe of
drawer who holds an MBA and has over 20
years of experience heading up high
volume high transaction companies which
you would definitely want a leader of a
company like Puma pay to have I'll
actually be interviewing ya later this
month which I'm looking forward to now
there are a ton of problems that Puma
pay is solving here one is they're
providing a universal token through
which businesses and customers can
interact second they're having the
currency fed through a system that
allows businesses and customers to synch
seamlessly where it's easy to pay easy
to accept the funds plenty of
customization that can
in terms of the payments set up whether
it's monthly as I mentioned paper use
paper time whatever works for the
particular transaction type and
businesses can set it up however they
want and this is something we've not
seen with crypto and number three and
this is really the catalyst that I think
gives the project so much potential is
that they're making it affordable for
everybody involved fees are way down
compared to the alternatives and that
will be a massive factor in influencing
adoption if kryptos are ever going to go
mainstream you need a set of tools like
this that's easy to integrate and easy
to use and follows regulations both on
the business and the customer side and
you also need a set of tools that will
mitigate risk as far as volatility and
liquidity we've talked about this so
much the way Puma paid does it provides
a bridge between the crypto holder and
businesses who want to start
capitalizing on what is a huge and
largely still untapped crypto market out
there I'm really enjoying following Puma
pay it'll be exciting to see what comes
next as they continue implementing
they're doing big things they're trying
to solve the kinds of problems that I've
been saying for years now need to be
solved before widespread crypto adoption
is going to be possible and as I said
I'll be interviewing their CEO in a few
weeks make sure to check that out and
learn more about Puma pay at Puma paid I
owe I've put a link right underneath
this video